[Music]  my name is ainsley earhart and i have  worked at fox news for 14 years  when i was a lot younger i came to new  york for the first time and i came in to  watch one of the morning shows this is  before fox was even on air and i got to  meet some of the anchors that we woke up  with every day and i was just blown away  my parents had this tv on top of a big  piece of furniture and mom would say  come here you got to watch this story  it's about high schoolers and here i am  face to face with these anchors and now  i get to be one of them this is so  unbelievable thank you all when the kids  come and they come outside on fox square  i get to meet them and that moment is  not lost on me i know what they're  feeling because i was that kid once and  i know that they have dreams  having an opportunity at fox news meant  everything to me it was my dream as a  child i still pinch myself when i walk  into fox news because all my dreams came  true there  you